I had a good year last year but am i
successful and the answer is no I don't
feel I am because I'm trying to build a
world that doesn't exist yet when you're
driving in your car and you get a text
and your phone goes beep we hate email
true we love the beat the buzz the ding
Oh have you gone and talked to a company
that's been in trouble and then spoken
to their team and then check in on them
after you've spoken to their leadership
team and what did that look like did you
notice a noticeable change I mean does
my work
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from author and speaker
Simon sonic and my take on its top 10
rules for success vol 2 rule number 5 is
my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
and as always as you're listening if
something really resonates with you
there's a message that really holds true
to you please leave it down in the
comments below and put it in quotes so
that other people can be inspired and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick with yourself as well
enjoy
people are always having visions and
missions and all this stuff
and when people ask me like what example
should I look - look what company should
I'm like here's an organization with a
vision a cause it was founded with a
cause it's an entrepreneurial venture
America is an experiment it's an
entrepreneurial venture where a bunch of
people got together and decided we
needed to start our own country because
there were certain obstacles that were
getting in the way of a vision that we
had of a better kind of country but a
kind of company right and they stated it
right at the beginning all men are
created equal endowed with these
unalienable rights amongst which include
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
and it's not a it's not just a
competitive statement like to be the
best to be the most respected that's not
what it was and I'm amazed how many
companies start their visions or
missions with those that terribly
egocentric language right it was an
ideal and the amazing thing is is we've
been good at it and bad at it in our
history but it's endured for 240 plus
years because we fundamentally believe
that we are at our best when we're
pursuing that but it is an ideal we will
never actually achieve all people are
equal but we will die trying and that's
the point and it's the same for a
company which is true vision inside a
company is something that has nothing to
do with your product it is an ideal to
which you will attempt to build and
advance that ideal through your company
with your product you'll never achieve
the ideal but you'll die trying and this
is what gives our work meaning this is
what it gives our lives purpose right
the difference between vision and a goal
is the finish line a goal is 26.2 miles
you can simply count the metrics and
know when you've completed your goal a
vision is having a crystal-clear sense
of what the finish line looks like but
no idea of how far away it is Wow
and it's and the reality is you'll spend
your entire life never actually crossing
the finish line but the joy that every
marathon you complete you feel like
you're getting closer every milestone
that you accomplish makes you feel like
you're getting closer and closer to the
ideal and this
what gives our life in our work meaning
success is an elusive thing right what
is it
and I think it's very interesting that
if most people can't define success well
it means you made X amount of dollars or
but if you make X amount of dollars you
spend more are you successful or what
means you come home happy everyday okay
how do you know when you're happy you
know so I think success is a funny thing
which is we all seem to pursue it but we
don't know how to measure it or actually
how to define it so how do you pursue
something that you can't measure
fascinating so when people say to me how
do you measure success the question we
all have to ask yourself am i successful
I don't know I mean I had a good year
last year and what does that mean does
that mean I made a lot of money does
that mean I was really happy I'll let
you decide right maybe neither maybe
both
I did good year last year but am i
successful and the answer is no I don't
feel I am because I'm trying to build a
world that doesn't exist yet I'm trying
to build a world in which 90% of people
go home at the end of the day feeling
fulfilled by the work that they do so I
definitely took a step a big step
forward towards I go but I'm still so
far away so somebody said to me then how
do you know if you're successful and the
answer is if it can go by itself and so
it is more interesting to me as a
measurement of success is not the the
the markers per se it's not the the
financial goal or the size of the house
that you want to buy though the nice
thing go for it those are but those are
not measurements of success those are
just nice things to collect along the
way for me it's momentum
I want to measure momentum which is you
know when something is moving and you
start to see it lose momentum you like
oh give it a push because you don't get
it push it's going to stop and an object
in stasis is much harder to get going it
requires a lot more energy to get
something started than it does to keep
it going right and so if you don't let
it stop and you can keep going it just
you know it still might slow down down
there but you can get it going again
much easier and for me the opportunity
is to get the ball rolling faster and
faster and faster and faster and faster
and bigger and bigger and bigger and
Slyke a snowball and my responsibility
is because it's not rolling downhill yet
it's not on automatic yet I need to
still keep it going to find that
critical mass where I can go
and at the point it can go by itself
without me then I will find something
else to do and that may not happen in my
lifetime I think we must all stop
measuring promotions salaries and these
things but rather measure the momentum
of your career does my career have
momentum can I see it moving in the
right direction can I see it gathering
moss
you know can I see that it's easy
becoming easier for me to keep the
momentum it's becoming easier for me to
grow the size of this thing it's
requiring less effort that's the thing
we need to measure that's the thing we
need to be cognizant of which is the
momentum of our career is not just the
markers that we think define our success
I did a little experiment with them with
a homeless person not like on them it's
not like electrodes with them
voluntarily helped me because the whole
idea of giving right you you will walk
down the street and you've all seen
someone begging and you either have or
haven't thrown a few pennies in their
cup when you do you feel good you bought
that feeling that is a legitimate
commercial transaction you know
commercial transactions are defined as
the exchange of consideration it was an
exchange of consideration here you gave
money you got the feeling of goodwill
you pay for that feeling if you didn't
give money you either feel nothing or
you feel bad you can't feel good by not
giving alright you paid for that feeling
so now the question is how is that
person encouraging us to give the joke
is they act like every corporation in
the world they talk about themselves
meeny-meeny-meeny me right like they sit
there with their little outdoor
advertising little sign right and it
says I'm homeless I'm hungry I got 12
kids I'm a veteran god bless they got it
all in they're trying to appeal to
somebody the religious vote the veteran
vote you know the child sympathizer
surround yourself with lots of pets go
for that one too right all in an attempt
to get something from someone takers not
givers right all about me well what
corporations do
we've added more RAM we've added more
rom with added more speed this one's
number one we're the biggest we're the
best we've been around since 1969 we're
better than them we're faster than them
we're more efficient than that one me
and me me me me me me me me me and so
even if we buy their product guess what
yeah man we don't feel much so I did
this little experiment I found them a
nice homeless lady on the streets of New
York who's willing to help out and I
learned that with her sign which was
pretty typical I'm homeless I'm hungry
remember she makes between 20 and 30
dollars a day for you know for a day's
worth of work eight to ten hours of
sitting there selling goodwill 8 to 10
hours she'll make 20 to $30 $30 is
considered a good day I changed her sign
and the new sign made her $40 in two
hours and then she left it's one of the
reasons she's homeless is because she's
decided that she only needs 20 to 30
dollars a day to live if she stayed she
would have made $150 the point is she
made 40 bucks in two hours where the
signs say the sign said if you only give
once a month please think of me next
time it has nothing to do with the taker
it has everything to do with the giver
and what are the objections people give
when they don't give I can't give to
everyone how do I know that they really
need it and so I address both those
concerns I know you can't get to
everyone so if you only give once a
month my cause is legitimate I will
still be here when you're ready to give
40 bucks two hours make it about them
not about you the fact of the matter is
100 percent of customers are people and
100 percent of clients are people and
100 percent of employees are people I
don't care how good your product is I
don't care how good your marketing is I
don't care how good your design is if
you don't understand people you don't
understand business we are social
animals we are human beings and our
survival depends on our ability to form
trusting relationships do you ever watch
Deadliest Catch on the Discovery Channel
that's flipping through channels one
night and Deadliest Catch came on and on
this episode just random they were in a
huge storm now for those of you who
don't know Deadliest Catch they take
these crab fishing boats out in the
Bering Sea which is like terrible and
they put cameras on them and we watch
right the reason that's I guess
significant is because these crab
fishermen have I think one of the top 5
deadliest jobs in the world
you know I don't know what the exact
number is but dozens of fishermen die
every year doing doing this we
apparently find that entertaining but it
actually is so they have cameras only on
five or six of the ships even though
there are many many me ships that go out
fishing every season and they don't
really come into proximity with each
other because you know that the oceans
huge and they usually sabotage each
other and give each other false
information because they're all
competitors they're all looking to get
the crabs and you know make sure that
they find them somebody else doesn't and
it's billed us right it's just business
that's okay we all do the same thing in
our own company and in this one episode
this big huge storm was so violent that
they had to bring all the pots which are
the big cages that they catch the crabs
and they bring all the pot back on the
boat and wait out the storm
and just by dumb luck one of the boats
that had cameras on it was in proximity
of a boat that didn't have cameras on it
and so they filmed they had secured all
their pots on the deck and so they
started filming the other boat and they
filmed a guy climbing on the outside of
the cage securing the pots and all of a
sudden a huge wave hits the side of the
boat
and the guys not there anymore and the
people on the boat with the camera start
screaming Man Overboard Man Overboard
Man Overboard and they turn their boat
towards where they think he might be
he's a stranger they don't know him they
don't know the crew members of the other
boat and yet they react and they turned
towards him and they find him in the
drink and for those of you don't
understand how dangerous this is if the
water is so cold that if you're in the
water for I think that it's a minute or
a minute 30
hypothermia will set in and you die and
they come upon him and he's screaming
don't let me die don't let me die and
they pull him onboard not out of the
woods yet they strip off his clothes
because it's wet and cold and they
wrapped blankets around him to prevent
hyperthermia from setting it and he
survives and it's overwhelming and the
captain comes down and this is all I'm
giving you can go watch it on TV your
camera comes the captain comes down and
he hugs this stranger this young man his
competitor he hugs this guy's if he's
his own son I lost it everybody is
crying and you realize what happened
here was a human interaction and the
reason they risked their own lives to
help this other person even though they
spend every other day trying to get
ahead and sabotage is because at the end
of the day they're all crab fishermen
and they know something about each other
and they know something about the risk
that they all take to do this and when
push comes to shove they will put
themselves out there to help each other
for no other reason than they get it
they're one of the same I will promise
you that every single member of that
crew that day went home with a feeling
of fulfillment I promise you that every
single person on that crew that day felt
more good in their hearts and in their
jobs than the richest day they've ever
pulled in my question is is what are you
doing to help the person next to you
don't you want to wake up and go to work
for the only reason that you can do
something good for someone else when you
want them to do that for you I'm a lover
of creative people and so any sort of
expression of how you see the world and
with different terminology is
fascinating to me and so even though I
myself I'm a photographer so I have that
visual aspect I'm a huge fan of modern
dance and spent a lot of time
sort of with dancers and in the dance
world and have you know tried my hand at
choreography just to see you know I'm
not good but I like the idea of trying
it you know and and so for me it's about
perspective which is when I when when
you hang out with dancers and you you
know you sort of learn to dance a little
bit or you learn to choreograph a little
bit or you learn to paint a little bit
you know I'm not a painter but I painted
a painting recently you know you know if
you if you understand
you know everything's connected right
you know it's like we conveniently
divide up our lives like here's my
personal life is my professional life um
you know is my social life I'm looking
to find balance it's just you you know
and all the same things apply and so if
you're you're good here you can apply
what you learn here to there you know
and so when you when you learn how
things interconnect and people into
connect somehow human relationships
working and present I mean you want to
learn about presence take a dance class
you learn all about how to present
yourself and be forwards
you're going to take an acting class
learn how to you know present your
speech people say Simon how'd you learn
this is like I'm exposed to all of it so
the tools I've learned have just mainly
been different perspectives on how other
people use their creative talents to see
the world and if I can get little pieces
of those they they help me in many many
different ways imagine we're standing in
a big empty room right and we're
standing in one corner and I give you a
simple instruction I want you to go to
that corner in a straight line right
hope you got a big deal right without
telling you I slipped a chair in front
of you what do you do you go around the
chair now you just disobeyed what I told
you to do I told you to go to that
corner straight line but this is the
amazing things about human beings which
is when we're given a clear destination
we use our own creativity on our own
sense of innovation and our own
problem-solving abilities to overcome
obstacles to get to the destination in
other words the destination is more
important than the route right we are
flexible about the route we're obsessed
with the destination reset we're
standing in the corner together and I
give you a simple instruction go
somewhere in this room in a straight
line and you say to me well where do you
owe me to get I'm like I don't know
you're smart figure it out
go in a straight line and so you pick a
point and you start walking and without
telling you I put a chair in front of
you and what do you do you come to a
grinding halt let's say would you stop
for you go will you put a chair in front
of me
or you'll make a sudden turn on go in
another direction right and this is the
problem it's the same obstacle the
difference is when you have a clear set
at the clear destination the obstacles
become easy to overcome when you don't
have a clear destination you keep coming
to a grinding halt and what we do in our
companies is we're counting the steps
we're taking along the route but we're
never looking at the destination right
the company has made a million dollars
this year we were only planning on
making eight hundred thousand where we
took ten steps you're any planning on
taking eight where're you going no clue
right we count the steps and so the
point is is that people want to feel
that the effort that they're exerting
actually are moving somewhere and so
successful measurement successful
recognition is not just for the steps
you take it's not just for the effort
it's that the effort you exerted moved
us closer to where we're trying to get
to and that get to should be some crazy
ideal my ideal is to live in a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning
you know inspire to go to work and
fulfilled by the work that they do and
the the couple of measurements that I
use are if the book is selling and I by
the way people ask me how many have you
sold I have no clue I've never asked the
publisher because they don't care I
really don't care how many I've sold
what I care about is the Amazon rankings
and that those are going steady or up
and not plummeting because that means
other people right because I don't have
a publicist I don't have a marketing
strategy on purpose I didn't hire one of
those companies to sell the book for me
and the reason is is because I'm not
interested in book sales I'm interested
in spreading an idea and so I just use
that as a metric to help me understand
am i sort of marketing in that because
the more I preach is it resonating you
know and so you have a couple of these
imperfect measurements that help you
understand are you going along the way
so it's not just great effort look what
you achieved because that's what we're
doing now right our goal is to increase
top-line revenues by 50 million dollars
for what reason right which is we have
to know the destination and then we say
amazing you took us that much closer if
we go to the right it's because we were
overcoming an obstacle if we hadn't gone
to the right we would have been stuck
forever thank you you know it's not
always straight lines it's not always
straight lines but it's in one direction
she's playing the cane out rarely are we
instant expert
you may have a particular gift or
affinity toward something but you still
get better you know people would pay me
high compliments when I started speaking
and then people who've seen me a year or
two later say that I'm even better and I
feel it why because you you you learn
more you know I think that hubris is
dangerous I think to think that you're
an expert and anything is a foolish
pursuit you're never you're never as
good as you could be there's always room
for improvement
there's always room to get better you
know that does mean you have to listen
to all the advice just you know not
necessarily does everybody know best but
but to believe that you can be better
and to believe that you can offer more
is a constant pursuit you know I used to
think being a public speaker meant being
poised and presenting in a way that was
compelling and speaking at the right
pace and that's that's a part of it but
but I have been taking more risks lately
doing things that are very unstructured
and very uncomfortable and I will now do
like if I have an hour to speak I'd
rather speak for 20 minutes and do 40
minutes worth of questions and who knows
how that's going to go and that to me is
the best and so I'm a better speaker
because now I'm Way more open to the
unknown where a few years ago that that
would have scared me
dopamine is the feeling that you found
something you're looking for or you
accomplished something you set out to
accomplish so you know that feeling you
get when you cross something off your
to-do list
that's dopamine feels awesome you know
when you when you have a goal to hit and
you achieve that goal you're like yes
you feel like you've won something right
that's dopamine the whole purpose of
dopamine is to make sure that we get
stuff done right the historical reason
for dopamine we would never eat if we
only waited to get until we got hungry
because there's no guarantee that we
would find food so dopamine exists to
help us go looking for food we get
dopamine when we eat which is one of the
reasons we like eating and so when you
see something that reminds you of
something that feels good we want to do
the behavior that helps us get that
feeling right so let's say you're out
there going for a walk and you see an
apple tree in the distance
you get a small head of dopamine and
then what it does is it focuses us on
our goals and now we start walking
towards the apple tree and have the
apple tree start to get a little bigger
we feel like we're making progress you
get another little shot of dopamine and
another little shallot dopamine until
you get to the Train you're like yes
okay this is why we're told you must
write down your goals your goals must be
tangible there's a there's a biological
reason for that we were very very
visually oriented animals you have to be
able to see the goal for it to
biologically stay focused right if you
don't write down your goals if you can't
see your goals it's very hard to get
motivated to get inspired for example
think about corporate visions right a
corporate vision is has to be something
we can see right that's why it's called
a vision you can see it right to be the
biggest most respected to be the
fastest-growing are not visions they're
nothing right what does that even look
like respected by whom your mother
yourself your friend your shareholders
who knows what's the metric dunno it's
Amorphis doesn't motivate us just like I
can't tell you you will get a bonus if
you achieve more you're going to ask me
how much more I'm going to say more
doesn't work you need a tangible goal
you need a tangible goal right here's a
great vision Martin Luther King I have a
dream that one day little black children
the little white children play on the
playground together and hold hands
together we can imagine that we can set
our sights on that and every time we
achieve a goal and achieve a metric and
achieve a milestone that makes us feel
like we're making progress to the vision
we can see we keep going and going and
going until we achieve something
remarkable they have to be able to see
it dopamine like I said dopamine is the
feeling you get when you set out to find
something you're looking for as well
talked about the to-do list I came home
from a trip just a couple days ago and I
had a bunch of errands to run and I
wrote down a little list of things I had
to do and off I went right and as I was
walking past I think of the dry cleaners
I remember I was walking past something
I remembered Who I have to do that I
hadn't written it down on my hadn't
written down on my to-do list so I went
in a
that's what I needed to do and then when
I came out I then wrote it on my to-do
list and then crossed it out because I
wanted the dopamine field good
dopamine comes with a warning dopamine
is highly highly highly addictive here
are some other things that release
dopamine alcohol nicotine gambling your
cell phone
oh you think I'm joking okay we've all
been told that you know if you wake up
in the morning and you crave a drink you
might be an alcoholic well if you wake
up in the morning the first thing you do
is check your phone before you even get
out of bed might be an addict
if you walk from room to room in your
own apartment holding your telephone you
might be an addict when you're driving
in your car and you get a text and your
phone goes beep we hate email true we
love the beat the buzz the ding oh right
you'll be there in 10 minutes and yet
you have to look at it right now you
might be an addict and even if you read
it and it says are you free for dinner
next Thursday and you have to reply
immediately you can't wait the 10
minutes you might be an addict and for
all you Gen Y is out there who like to
think that you're better at multitasking
beause you grew up with the technology
then why do you keep crashing your cars
when you're texting
you're not you're not better at
multitasking you're better getting
distracted in fact if you look at the
statistics ad D and ADHD have diagnosis
of AD D and ADHD have risen 66% in the
past 10 years okay ad D and ADHD is a
frontal lobe disorder right are you
telling me out of nowhere 66% of our
youth has the frontal lobe problem where
did that come from no it's a
misdiagnosis right what what are the
what are the symptoms of a dopamine
addiction to technology distractibility
inability to get things done easily
easily distracted you know shortness of
attention it's all the same thing so we
misdiagnosed things it's this it's the
addictive quality of dopamine we can
also get addicted to performance in our
companies when all they do is give us
numbers to hit numbers to hit numbers to
hit and a bonus you get and a bonus you
get and a bonus you get all they're
doing is feeding us with dopamine we
can't help ourselves all we do is want
more more MORE it's no surprise that the
bank's destroyed the economy because one
of the things we know about dopamine
addicts is they will do anything to get
another hit sometimes at the sacrifice
of their own resources and their
relationships and the alcoholic gambling
addict or drug addict
ask them how their relationships are
doing and if they've squandered any of
their resources it's an addiction
dopamine is dangerous if it is
unbalanced it is hugely helpful when in
a comfortable and balanced system but
when unbalanced it's dangerous and it's
destructive there's a brilliant leader
by the name of David mark hey who wrote
a book called turn the ship around and
he had an experience as a submarine
captain on the USS Santa Fe where he
realized that as much as he knew about
submarining you know he'd been a
submarine or his whole career that put
on this new submarine he learned the
hard way they actually didn't know how
to submarine work he made an order that
nobody knew how to do it because there
was that didn't exist on that sub and so
he realized he had no choice but to
trust his people and he went through
this transformation as a leader of
telling everybody what to do to allowing
people to tell him what should be done
and I've learned a lot from him and I
highly recommend his book and and I
really learned that which
is you know at the top of the
organization as David says the people
have all the authority the leaders have
all the authority but at the bottom they
have all the context right
and so you can't just push all the
context up you have to push the
authority down and so the
responsibilities of leadership is to
train people make sure that they have
the skill set help build their
confidence that they have the confidence
to do what needs to be done you have to
have competence and confidence
right and that that's your job that's
the only job of the leader makes it like
like a parent
make sure they have competence and
confidence you know make sure your kids
get schooling and make sure that they
believe in themselves and then leave
them you know and so I've done the same
thing instead of sort of showing people
how I would do it I want them to learn
how it's done you know and feel good
about themselves and then just however
they do it is how they do it yeah you
know and the result is remarkable people
feel better about coming to work I feel
like they have something to contribute
they feel more valuable as opposed to
just being told this is how I would do
it or I'm going to do it this way or do
it my way
so yeah completely changing my
understanding of my job as more like a
parent than a manager has had remarkable
impact it's easy to pull things back
it's very hard to ramp things up and I'd
rather start with something that's too
big and pull it back into reality then
start with something that's so easy that
you can't really get it up for example
you know don't set your goals
realistically set them entirely
unrealistically I mean shoot for 80 and
be disappointed when you hit 70 as
opposed to shooting for 20 and being
ecstatic when you hit 21 we beat our
goal yeah but it was logo you know I
think I think to be frustrated and
achieving something rather than ecstatic
and achieving less is a better way to
live not to mention your team or so I'm
a great believer in that the greater
good like those things there's like so
big they're ridiculous I mean like you
know my goal is 100 your goal is called
world peace
I know daunting you know but that's the
idea if I fail and I certainly won't
achieve it in my lifetime I'd like to
think that what I'll contribute towards
that ridiculous idealistic nonsense goal
will be more than if I say if I can just
be happy by myself in my little house
you know right I mean that's nice and
all but I like the idea of contributing
to your neighbor as well you speak to
businesses and companies and leadership
teams and employees and stuff without
mentioning names and I want to put you
on the spot but have you gone and talked
to a company that's been in trouble and
then spoken to their team and then check
in on them after you've spoken to their
leadership team and what did that look
like did you notice a noticeable change
did they come to you and tell you that
this has helped our organization out in
our culture is much improved because of
it you mean does my work
I mean sure here's the problem with
myself you got to do it and I am not I'm
not anybody's like you know mom or dad
I'm not going to do it for you and I
have a very less fair approach of it I
once had a one-sided client this is a
bunch of years ago that said what
guarantee do I have that your stuff will
work which my answer was none like I I'm
giving you a tool you can like a hammer
you can use it broadly or narrowly you
can build a table you can build a house
it's the same tool you can use for
marketing if you use ik completely
revitalize your entire culture and even
though I'm going to sell you the most
beautiful hammer I'm not going to
guarantee the structural integrity of
the house right it's your business you
want to ignore all my stuff ignore it I
don't care it's your and if your
business collapses you know what happens
to me nothing
like I don't mean to be cold about it
like of course I want the people I work
with to do well but it's not mine it's
theirs and I take no emotional
responsibility but the decisions they
make so yes there are many people that
I've had the pleasure of working with
some who work for dysfunctional
organizations that went up the hard
journey of completely changing the way
they lead and completely revitalizing
their culture and it has great success
it's not because of me it's because of
them right at the same time there are
many people who came in like all of
amazing speech and did nothing you know
thanks that was great you know and I
don't it's of course it's going to fail
you know so I I think that we have too
much especially in the consulting world
or the design world everybody so
paternalistic about it and designers are
famous for this right they get so
personally offended when the client
chooses the wrong thing through six
videos still they know we're trying to
help them
or who cares like it's their freaking
business right that's what you find
I've had that instead of arguing with
somebody for them to the right choice
which because we genuinely want to help
them what I have found is if you push
the accountability that's because when
we argue we're taking accountability
this is better this will help you we're
taking responsibility accountability but
if we say look we've been doing this a
bunch of years we know more about design
than you do I'm telling you for every
reason that I can outline for you why
this will help you more but if you don't
want to do it that's fine it's your
business do what you want the minute you
switch the accountability and put it all
on them amazingly they're much more open
to your opinion because now they're
responsible
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because I need to ask me
to if there's someone you like in a
profile in the next top ten check out
the link in the description and go and
cast your vote I'd also love to know
what was your favorite message from this
video what did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or in your business
please leave it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to the
YouTube channel obtain eudaimonia thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word doing that animated
review and posting it to your channel I
really really really appreciate the
support and I'm so glad that you enjoyed
the book this book explains the secrets
of how one word can transform you and
your business so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
the greatest measure of human
aggressors working together none of us
can solve complex problems by ourselves
none of us can lift a heavy weight by
ourselves we can't build big things by
ourselves but when we learn to cooperate
and trust each other and share what we
know with others we work together and we
can solve the most complex problems
build the most remarkable things and let
the heaviest of weight so definitely
cooperation and trust what I learned is
that I don't have to know all the
answers and if I don't I don't have to
pretend that I do the opportunity to ask
others for help and admit when we don't
know things and even admit when we make
mistakes means that people will rush to
our aid it will be there to help us if
we claim we know the answer is we hide
the mistakes we make then people will
think things are fine and so they'll
leave us alone
and it's not that people don't want to
help us they say is that they don't know
when they can I wake up every single
morning with a very clear sense of
purpose
it's to inspire people to do what
inspires them so together we can change
our world and I have a very clear vision
of the world I want to live in I would
like to live in a world in which the
vast majority of people wake up every
single morning inspired to go to work
they feel safe when they're there and
they come home at the end of the day
fulfilled by the work that they do and
I've committed all of my work and it
doesn't matter what form it takes with
it speaking or writing or teaching or
advising or doesn't even matter what
form it takes in some way shape or form
to help advance that vision and move
closer and closer to it and my friends
are my allies you know we're part of an
army that are trying to build as well
together that's why I come to
conferences like this it gives me a
bully pulpit to share that vision with
the hope that some of the companies in
the room will start to change the way
they least view what they're doing and
change the way they do things because
I'm just I'm just a preacher that's all
I am
unless companies actually affect the
change my vision will never come to life
and so well I know that so it's going to
take a lot of us and we all play a
different part we all play pieces of a
jigsaw puzzle and of which I'm just one
people